your favorite thing about Ben Simmons he  a baby cry  nothing he pathetic  he can't shoot uh three free throws you  know my favorite thing is they can't  make any shot from anywhere literally  going to that Garden he'll brick  everything remember that one thing where  he like charge up to the rim had like an  open shot passed out to Kyrie Kyrie you  could hear him yelling shoot shoot drops  it off Simmons dishes that he's scared  to shoot nothing what's he look like a  dead or something he was a Kindle Gotta  Give him props for that I don't like him  at all thank God he's out of the city uh  I don't really have a favorite thing  about that I don't got a favorite thing  I'm not thinking about him he stopped